it's the final campaign appearance
before the election so everything had to
be right that's why Slovak Prime
Minister robert fico opened with the
rhetorical big guns we will not follow
any EU quotas we won't allow one single
Muslim to live in our country actually
Slovakia hasn't been affected by the
refugee crisis the country which has a
population of 5 million has only taken
in 300 migrants so far still fears are
running high yes I'm scared that some
might be coming the whole world is full
of them maybe they're coming here to
look there are so many of them there are
children sick people who's supposed to
take care of them all
no it can't be any good protect Slovakia
proclaim Prime Minister FICO's election
posters in Bratislava
and his aren't the only ones all parties
in the election have rejected the notion
of taking in refugees for many Slovaks
it's the fear of the unknown so far not
many refugees have entered the country
but they could eventually come and no
one knows what that's going to be like
that's the feeling that's the fear that
many politicians here are trying to
exploit anti-refugee propaganda is very
common but not everyone here agrees with
it Elena and other volunteers cook for
Refugees here in this little kitchen
west of Bratislava they prepare simple
meals but they don't have a lot of
support very easily switch against some
enemy who will take from them even more
and because there are almost no refugees
in Slovakia elena brings the food the
other volunteers prepare across the
border to austria beside the highway
between Bratislava and Vienna there's a
small container village around 80 people
from Afghanistan Syria and Iran
immediately the image of the thread
security threat or something it's broken
you know there are people like while the
refugee crisis has become a hot button
issue in the Slovak elections other
problems are getting swept under the rug
trouble in the healthcare and education
systems are not being addressed by any
of the politicians to play emotional
card for them to tell people this is
what we've done and this is what you
gained during the last four years or so
and emotions are much stronger in
attracting voters to come to the poll
regardless of whether refugees are
coming to Slovakia are not robert FICO's
campaign strategy seems to be working
according to polls his government is set
to be reelected things will likely get
more complicated in July when Slovakia
assumes the EU council presidency
Bratislava will then be responsible for
coordinating a European solution to the
refugee crisis